大家好我是Jim,這裡是AI Notebook
這是史丹佛CS336系列的終極
上集我們把成本算出來了
有成上參數量,再成上資料量
1000張顯示卡要跑144天,一個參數要吃掉16個位元組
所以一張卡根本裝不下一個700億參數的模型
算完之後問題不會消失,它只會變得更具體
終極要回答的就是接下來那三個問題
第一,這個模型到底跑不跑得動,你要怎麼把它切開
看到幾千張卡上面
第二
這筆錢花對了沒有
你憑什麼在還沒開始訓練之前
就決定模型要多大
資料要為多少
第三
五個月燒完之後
你怎麼知道它到底有多好
這三個問題對應的是
課程的第七到第十二講
而他們其實共用同一種能力
我們先從一份論文附錄裡的數字說起
Meta在Lama3的技術報告裡
很誠實地記下了那次訓練期間
所有的中段
他處在第七講
把這一頁調出來給學生看
裡面有一個數字是這樣的
光是顯示卡故障造成的中斷
就有148次
大約佔掉全部中斷的三成
另外還有32次是機器臨時要維護
根本沒有排進計劃裡
而且這還只是民豬壞的那一種
他主說業界更怕的是另一種
顯示卡不報錯
那只是默默的回傳錯的數字
你的訓練照跑
損失曲線照降
等你發現的時候
錢已經燒掉了
你可以想成一個工地
你手上有10萬個工人
每天都有人請假
還有幾個人在偷偷把螺絲鎖歪
而這個工地連續好幾個月不能停工
這就是這一集開始的地方
當你的計算規模大到這個程度
股漲不是意外
它是日常
塔楚在第七講的開場
只講了一句話
就把整堂課的鏡頭拉遠了
他說
計算的基本單位已經不是一顆顯示卡了
新的單位是一整座資料中心
這句話聽起來像羞恥
可是他真的改變了每一件事
你在一臺機器上寫程式的時候
講的是怎麼把資料
從記憶體搬到計算單元旁邊
這是上集的主題
現在你要想的是
怎麼把資料從這棟樓的這一排機櫃
搬到走到另一邊的那一排機櫃
距離變遠了
中間多了交換器跟網路線
所有的老問題全部重來一次
而且每一項都被放大好幾個數量級
這也是為什麼剛才那148次故障
值得放在最前面
當你的計算單位變成一座資料中心
可靠性就變成演算法設計的一部分
而不是維修部門的事
接下來的兩講就是再教一件事
你手上有一個裝不進任何一臺機器的模型
你要怎麼把它切成幾千份
攤在這座資料中心裡
也讓這幾千份還能像一臺機器一樣一起工作
我們先把上集那本賬翻回來一頁上集算過
一個參數不是隻佔一份位置
他自己要一份
他的修正量要一份優化器
還要幫他記兩筆滑動平均
加起來大概要吃掉16個位元組
他除在第七講
把這筆賬講得更白
這16個位元組
其實等於你把同一份權重存了5次
所以8張H100
加起來的記憶體聽起來很多
真的拿來訓練的話
頂多塞了下一個60億參數的模型
而現在隨便一個主流的開放權重模型
有700億參數起跳
你看得出來這中間的缺口有多大
你可以想成搬家
上級
我們再算一個房間放不放得下一張床
現在的問題是這張床比整棟房子還大
把它切開
一部分放這間一部分放那間
然後讓他們合起來
還能像一張完整的床一樣用
這件事聽起來很荒謬
可是接下來我們要講的
全部都是在講
怎麼把這件荒謬的事做對
而且做到讓幾千張卡看起來像一張卡
要把一個模型切開
聽起來有無限多種可能
實際上只有三種切法
Tasu在第八講用了一張很好的圖
同一個畫面一疊資料一串矩陣
你只要換一個方向下刀
就得到一種平行化
第一種是沿著資料橫著切
每臺機器拿到不同的一批資料
模型本身每臺都存一份完整的
這叫資料平行
第二種是沿著寬度直著切
每一個矩陣都被PO成好幾片
每臺機器只拿一片
這叫張量平行
張量你就想成上集講的那張數字表格
第三種是沿著深度切
模型有80層前20層放這一臺
接下來20層放下一臺
這叫管線平行
我用工廠來講可能更清楚
資料平行是開了四條一模一樣的產線
每一條都能做完整臺車
只是訂單分的做
張量平行是同一道工序
找四個人一起做
一人負責一腳
管線平行是傳統的輸送帶
第一站裝底盤
第二站裝引擎
這三種分工各有各的代價
而選哪一種
答案不在演算法
在你機房的網路線上
我們一種一種看
先看最常用的資料
平行四臺機器
各存一份完整的模型
一批資料切成四份
每臺各算一份
算完之後
手上都有一份自己的修正量
問題就在這裡
四臺機器各學各的
四份修正量不一樣
如果放著不管
四個模型會越走越開
最後會變成四個不同的模型
所以每一步結束之前
四臺機器要對一次賬
把四份修正量加起來
平均掉
再各自更新
這個動作
有一個正式的名字叫All Reduce
中文可以說成全體歸約
前面那個Reduce的意思是做加總這一類的運算
後面那個All的意思是
賺出來的結果要送回給每一個人
你可以想成四個店員各自記了一天的賬
讓大家把賬本攤在桌上
加總
然後每個人再抄一份一樣的總賬回去
他主說
這個領域的效能分析沒有那麼玄
你只要數兩件事
他呼叫了幾次集體通訊
每次搬多少東西
資料平行漂亮的地方是簡單
代價是每一臺機器都得存一份完整的模型
記憶體完全沒有省到
第二種是張量平行
既然每臺都存一份完整的模型太浪費
那乾脆讓每臺只存一部分
模型裡面最大的東西就是那些數字表格
張量平行就是把每一張表格沿著寬度剖開
這臺機器各拿四分之一
一筆資料進來
四臺各自算自己那一片
最後再對一次賬
合起來
答案跟原本一模一樣
這就像一道很寬的工序
本來一個人從頭做到尾
現在四個人並排站
一人負責一段
做完
拼回去
張量
平行有一個非常珍貴的性質
資料
平行要靠加大批次量
才能攤平通訊成本
可是批次量是有上限的
超過某個規模
你再加大
模型學到的東西也不會等比增加
所以批次量在大規模訓練裡
是一種要精打細算的資源
而張量平行
完全不花這個資源
它切的是模型的寬度
跟你一次喂多少資料無關
代價是什麼
代價是
它每一層都要對賬一次通訊
非常密集
密集到它幾乎只能在同一臺機器裡面做
這一句話
等一下會變成整張最重要的那條鐵綠
第三種是管線平行
沿著深度切
模型有80層
你把前20層放第一臺機器
加20層放第二臺資料
從第一臺進去
算完20層
把中間結果傳給第二臺
第二臺接著算
這就是輸送帶
輸送帶有一個很現實的毛病
第一臺在算的時候
後面三臺在發呆
如果傳到第四臺
前面三臺又沒事做了
四臺機器裡永遠只有一臺在真的工作
這段空窗
在課堂上叫氣泡解法
是把一大批資料切成很多小批
讓他們一個接一個上輸送袋
慢慢的整條線就都填滿了
小批切得越多氣泡越小
代價又回到剛才那件事
你得有夠大的批資量可以切
管線平行還有一個代價不會寫在論文裡
Katsu轉述了他最近聽到的一段對話
某個前沿實驗室的人說
我們整個團隊只有兩個人
真的搞懂管線平行怎麼運作
其中一個已經離職了
所以他們的訓練系統
現在靠著一個人撐著
他用了一個詞形容那個人
沉重人
你就知道這件事在工程上有多不好惹
講到這裡
資料平行最大的問題還沒有解決
每一臺機器都要存一份完整的模型
要解決它
我們得先看懂一個等式
這個等式是第七講的核心
剛才那個對賬的動作
其實可以被切成兩個更小的動作
第一個動作
四臺機器把自己的賬本切成四段
每臺只負責加總自己那一段這一步
叫Reduce Scatter
中文可以說成
分段規約做完之後
每臺手上有一段正確的總賬
第二個動作每臺把自己算好的那一段廣播出去四段拼起來
每個人就都有完整的總賬了
這一步叫all gather全體收集
這兩步加起來跟直接對一次賬的結果一模一樣
他說這是這一講你唯一需要背下來的橫等式
那為什麼重要
因為當你發現對賬可以被切成兩半
你就會發現中間那個狀態非常有價值
每臺機器只拿著一段總賬
這件事聽起來像缺陷
可是換個角度看
那就是每臺機器只需要存四分之一的東西
整條瀑布就是從這個念頭開始的
這個念頭做成系統就叫ZERO
名字的意思是把冗餘降到零
TASU用了一個具體的例子
一個75億參數的模型
攤在64個加速器上面
一開始什麼都不切
每一臺都存完整的一份
每一張卡要吃掉120GB的記憶體
讓我們一段一段往下切
第一段優化器
那兩筆動量最肥
可是它只有在更新參數的那一瞬間才用得到
那就不要每臺都存切成64份
每臺只管自己那一段
120掉到31.4
第二段
提度也是一樣的道理
你只需要自己負責的那一段提度
其他的加總完就可以丟掉
31.4掉到16.6
第三段最徹底
連參數本身都切開
需要哪一層
就臨時跟大家要過來
用完就丟
16.6掉到1.9
重新看一次
這條瀑布120GB
掉到不到2GB
模型一樣大
資料一樣多
結果一模一樣
只是沒有人在存重複的東西了
這是我在整門課裡
也看過最漂亮的一張圖
你聽到第三段的時候
心裡應該會冒出一個疑問
參數都不留在本地
每算一層都要跟其他機器要一次
那不是要搬風了嗎
這確實是它的代價
通訊量會變成原本的1.5倍
可是它實際跑起來的開銷
比大家想像的低很多
原因是一個很聰明的安排
機器在算第一層的時候
負責通訊的那條線路並沒有閒著
它已經在背景把第二層的參數要過來了
等第一層算完第二層早就到了
這就像餐廳的備料
廚師在炒這道菜的時候
助手已經把下一道菜的料切好放在旁邊
所以廚師從來不用停下來等
這一招你可能已經用過了
只是不知道它的來歷
Pytorch裡那個叫FSTP的東西
中文是全切片資料平行
那其實就是這條瀑布的第三段
這條瀑布的效果有多實在
塔數給了一個數字
同樣是8張H100的一臺機器
什麼都不切的時候你只塞了下60億參數
切到最徹底之後
同一臺機器可以塞500億
同樣的硬體同樣的錢
訓練的模型大了將近8倍
講到這裡你可能會覺得
這一整套像是隻有大公司
才碰得到的黑魔法
第八講
整堂課就是來破除這個印象的
他處打開編輯器
當場把這三種平行化各寫一次
每一種都只有十幾行
我最喜歡的是資料平行那一段
他先寫一個最普通的訓練迴圈
讀一批資料
算損失
反向傳播
更新參數
然後他再反向傳播
算完之後更新參數之前
插進去一行
把所有機器的梯度對一次張
平均掉
就這樣 結束了
這一行就是完整的資料平行
哈處講了一句我覺得很傳神的話
他說 從優化器自己的角度看
好像什麼事都沒有發生
我就是在跑我的梯度下降
只是有人偷偷把我的梯度混進來了
你可以想成
四個人同時在改同一份文件
改完之後有人把四份修改合併
再把合併後的版本發回給每個人
從每個人的角度看
他只是在改文件
可是那份文件已經悄悄變成大家的共識了
分散式訓練沒有那麼神秘
它是幾個1980年代就有的通訊原語
重新排列組合而已
這樣我們可以回答那個問題了
三種切法到底要怎麼選
踏出的答案很乾脆
答案不在演算法
在你機房的線路上
顯示卡衝擊的網路是分層的
在機器裡面通常有八張卡
這八張卡之間走的是
揮達自己的專用線路叫NV-Link
快到什麼程度
快到跟顯示卡讀自己的記憶體只差幾倍
可是這八張卡想跟隔壁機器的卡講話
就得走出機殼走網路交換器
一條線叫Infiniband
它述說
同樣一條通道走出機殼之後大概慢8倍
再往外還有一層
整個重集
大概在256張卡以內
任何兩張卡都能直接快速對話
超過這個規模
風包就得再爬一層
交換器速度又降一級
所以整個機房其實是一組同心圓
圓心的水管最粗
往外一圈就細一截
這件事的意思是
你手上那三種切法
同訊量最大的那一種
必須放進最粗的水管裡
而通訊量最大的就是張量平行
每一層都要對一次帳
一臺機器裡剛好有8張卡
這兩件事一對上
那條鐵綠就自己出來了
Tatsu贏了一份實測資料
張量平行切到8張卡以內
吞吐量大概損失1層到1層2
這是可以接受的代價
切到16張卡
也就是跨出了機殼的吞吐量直接掉4層2
切到32張
再掉6層5
這條曲線只講一件事
張量平行的甜蜜點就是8
而8這個數字不是理論算出來的
它就是一臺機器裡有幾張卡
所以那句
到處都看得到的張量
平行射8
不是迷信
它是機殼的形狀決定的
整套決策流程其實很短
第一步張量平行開到8
先把單機吃滿
第二步模型還是塞不下
才跨出機殼
用那條瀑布的第三段
或者管線平行第三步
剩下的卡全部拿去做資料平行
他屬於給了一個例外
他說他知道的例子裡
只有DeepSeek V3
完全不用張量平行
改成16路管線平行
加上64路專家
平行專家平行
是因為它是專家混合架構
模型裡面有很多份專家
那就乾脆一臺機器管幾份
這個例外很有意思
因為它通常代表一件事
那家公司的機器之間
線路沒有別人好
機器排好了
現在換一個完全不同的問題
它似乎在第九講一開場
給了學生一個情境
假設你有一個很有錢的朋友
他借你十萬張H100用一個月
條件是你要造出
當下最強的開放權重模型
這個情境的重點不在錢
在於你只有一次機會
你不可能訓練20個大模型來挑一個
那筆錢只夠燒一次
所以模型要多大
資料要為多少
學習率設多少
全部都必須在你按下開始之前就決定好
踏鼠把深度學習過去的做法形容為
又舊又討厭
就是訓一堆大模型
一邊調參數一邊看
它變好
那在你有無限次機會的時候可行
現在完全不可行
所以有了新的做法
它稱之為新的樂觀主義
你先訓練一大堆很小的模型
小到便宜的可以隨便試
從他們身上找出一條規律
然後把這條規律往上外推
直接算出大模型該長什麼樣子
這就是Scaling Law
中文可以說成縮放定律
那其實不是在預言人工智慧的未來
它在解決一個很務實的問題
你怎麼用小模型的錢
來到大模型的答案
在往下走之前
他主做了一件我很欣賞的事
他把這件事的來歷交代清楚
很多人以為縮放定律是這幾年才發明的東西
是某種對人工智慧未來的預言
他主說不是
他認為第一篇真正意義上的縮放定律論文
發表在1993年的NeuroLabs
作者來自貝爾實驗室
裡面有幾個名字你可能聽過
Vladimir Vapnik, Corina Cortez
那篇論文說
在很大的資料庫上訓練一個分類器
計算量太大了
我們希望在真的訓完之前
就能預測哪一個比較好
他述說他備課的時候
重讀這篇論文
很驚訝他有多超前
因為換成今天的說法就是一模一樣的事
他還提到2017年百度的一份研究
那是最早在大規模神經網路上做這件事的
涵蓋了機器翻譯、語音辨識跟影像
所以縮放定律不是憑空冒出來的新宗教
它是一條有30年曆史的學術脈絡
它做的事情也不懸
就是把統計學習理論裡那些寫不出具體數值的上界
換成一條真的量得出來的經驗曲線
縮放定律長什麼樣子
橫軸放資料量
縱軸放模型的錯誤率
兩軸都取對數
你會看到一條直線
這條直線的斜率就是全部的重點
他告訴你資料每多10倍
錯誤率會掉多少
他說給了幾個實測值
機器翻譯跟語音辨識都比較陡
語言建模只有0.095
是裡面最平的一條
這個數字小到有點讓人沮喪
把資料加10倍
損失也只掉一點點
為什麼語言這麼難
他說用了一個很漂亮的推導
想象你要在一個正方形裡面
估計一個函數
你在裡面撒了100個點
切成10x10的小格子
每一格取一次平均
這樣就估得不錯了
現在把場景換成三維
同樣要讓每一格里面有一個點
你需要的點數變成1000個維度
再往上加需要的點數是指數爆炸的
所以斜率其實是在告訴你
這個任務背後有多少個內在的維度
斜率越平代表維度越高越難學
語言的斜率遠比教科書上任何一個標準情況都平
這本身就在說語言是一個維度高到誇張的問題
這也順便解釋了
為什麼大家非得把治療量堆到照這個等級不可
知道曲線長什麼樣
我們可以問那個真正花錢的問題
你手上有一筆固定的算力預算
該把它花在一個大模型讀比較少的資料
還是一個小模型讀比較多的資料
這就是Chinchia那篇論文在回答的問題
它是DeepMind在2022年做的Tatsu說
裡面有三種做法
它最推薦的是第二種
叫等算力分析
做法非常直觀
你先固定一個算力預算
在這個預算之內
你可以訓練一個很小的模型讀很多資料
也可以訓練一個很大的模型只讀一點點資料
你把中間各種組合都試一遍
把損失畫出來
你會得到一個碗的形狀
太小的模型學不動
損失高
太大的模型資料不夠
也學不好
損失一樣高
碗底那個點
就是這筆預算最划算的模型大小
然後你換一個更大的預算
再畫一個碗
神奇的事情發生了
這些碗的碗底連起來
在對數座標上是一條漂亮的直線
你只要把這條直線往右上延伸
你就可以回答一個
從來沒有人訓練過的規模
該用多大的模型
一條直線,讀出來的答案就是那個被引用到爛掉的比例
每一個參數大約應該配20個Token的訓練資料
卡處特別強調,這篇論文
最漂亮的地方不是這個數字
是三種完全不同的推導方法,答案几乎一樣
而在Chinchua之前,業界流行的比例大約只有2比1
那是GPT-3那個年代的做法
也就是說,同樣一筆算力預算
資料量跟模型大小的比例前後差了10倍
為什麼之前會估錯?
他處指出了一個很具體的技術原因跟學習率的排成有關
現在的訓練幾乎都用一種先升後降的曲線
一開始把學習率慢慢拉起來
然後沿著一條餘旋曲線一路降到接近0
這條曲線的形狀是為你預計的總資料量剋制出來的
所以你不能拿一次完整訓練跑到一半的檢查點
去代表一個只訓練到一半資料量的模型
因為那兩件事的學習率完全不一樣
他處說這個坑一天到晚在咬人
之前那份研究就是踩了這個坑
才會把比例估得那麼低
群七啦
還有一個很少人講了後續
他處說這是他覺得最有趣的一段
剛才那三種推導方法
其實有一個小瑕疵
前兩種算出來的答案几乎一模一樣
第三種卻有點偏
他處說他的學生問過他
為什麼第三種差這麼多
他當時的回答是我不知道
說放定律有時候就是有點雜訊
去年有一群Epoch AI的研究者
好奇到不行決定重跑一次
第三種方法
困難在於原始的訓練資料
他們拿不到
所以他們做了一件很像見識的事
他們拿取值工具
直接從論文那張圖的圖片上面
把每一個資料點的座標一顆一顆挖出來
挖完之後重新擬合
結果發現原作者的資料完全沒問題
是曲線擬合那一步沒做好
殘差有明顯的偏移修正之後
第三種方法的答案跟前兩種幾乎完全對上
這個故事我很喜歡的地方是它的方向
大部分的重現研究
目的是要推翻原本的結論
這一次的重現反而讓原本的結論站得更穩
就是比例這個數字
後來發生了什麼事
他屬在第十一獎給了一把很有畫面的尺
不過他先講了一件很現實的事
Chad GPT出現之後
前沿實驗室對
縮放的細節幾乎全面封口
他說他去問過那些公司的人
對方的回答是
我們什麼都不會告訴你
所以這一獎其實是在做考古
從少數還願意誠實公開的論文裡面往回挖
Meta在Lama3上自己重做了一次
等算力分析
得到的比例大約是39比1
騰訊的會員大模型做出來是96比1
而最極端的是一份叫MiniCPM的研究
他們推出來的比例是192比1
他處的評語很直接
他說他沒有看過任何其他人推出這個數字
這是一個離群值
所以這把尺攤開來看
從21路滑到192
各家算出來的答案差了將近10倍
他處的結論是
Chinchilla真正被反覆驗證的從來不是20
而是那套等算力分析的方法本身
20不是憲法
它只是一個起點
為什麼所有人都在往右滑
答案跟數學無關
跟商業模式有關
阿樹說
在Chinchilla的年代
大家問的是
這筆算力怎麼訓練出最好的模型
可是模型變成產品之後
問題整個換掉了
變成我這個模型要被幾億人用
每一次對話都要付一次錢
訓練是一次性的支出
推理是永遠都在跑的水電費
你可以想成買房跟租房
訓練成本是頭期款
你痛一次
推理成本是房貸
每個月都要付
而且要付很多年
所以現在的做法變成
寧可在訓練上多花好幾倍的錢
也要把模型做得更小一點
因為小模型每被呼叫一次都便宜一點
而那個一點會被乘上幾億次
這就是為什麼今天的模型都在超訓位
這資料遠遠超過計算上最划算的量
他處說他前一天才看到
最新的昆模型訓練資料是30兆個Token
回想一下上集那個15兆的例子
現在已經是他的兩倍了
所以那把尺會繼續往右滑
不是因為有人發現了新的頂履
是因為推理賬單一直在增加
推理賬單這四個字
把我們帶進第十講
這一講的講者是Percy Lam
他開場先講了一句話
把推理的地位擺正
做評測要生成Token
讓模型多想一會再回答
要生成Token,用強化學習訓練他
要一直生成
Token推理是這一切的底層
而他的物理性質跟訓練完全不一樣
每次跟模型講話其實有兩個階段
這兩個階段的個性差非常多
第一個階段叫Pre-fill
你把整段輸入丟給模型
他先把這段話讀完一次
關鍵是所有的字可以同時處理,顯示卡的計算單元全部忙起來,這是他最擅長的事
第二個階段叫DECODE模型,開始一個字一個字往外吐,這一步沒辦法同時做
他得先知道第一個字是什麼,才能決定第二個字
所以同一顆模型在同一張卡上,前半秒跟後面那幾秒完全是兩種人格
這也解釋了一件你天天都在體驗的事
為什麼模型的第一個字要等一下才出來,出來之後卻能穩定的一個一個吐
也解釋了為什麼幾乎所有的模型服務輸入的價格都比輸出便宜很多
為什麼第二階段這麼慢?
Percy給了一個很乾淨的算法,叫算術強度
他問的是,每從記憶體搬一個位元組進來
會拿他去做幾次運算,你可以想成加油
加完又可以跑300公里,那趟很划算
如果你沒跑5公里就要回加油站一次
但你大部分的時間都花在路上,引擎再強也沒有用
H100這張卡有一個天生的門檻
他的計算能力除以他的記憶體頻寬
得到的數字大約是295
這個數字的意思是,每搬一份資料進來
至少要拿它做295次運算
才算把這張卡用滿
現在你回頭看
第二個階段
模型一次只吐一個字
也就是說
它要把整個模型的權重
全部從記憶體搬過來一次
只為了處理一個字
這個幣值大概是多少
答案11
差了將近300倍
所以你會看到一個
很違反直覺的畫面
你打開監控
檢視
卡的使用率明明沒有滿
可是文字就是慢慢的跑
它不是不夠力
它是在等貨
這也是為什麼
服務一個模型要看兩個指標
一個是你按下送出之後多久看到第一個字
叫延遲
另一個是整臺機器每秒總共吐出多少字
這叫吞吐量
Percy說
如果這堂課你只記一件事
那就是速度的關鍵
全部在記憶體
有一個很自然的想法可以救這件事
就是同時服務很多人
既然搬一次全種子處理一個字
太浪費
那我一次處理100個人的下一個字
全種子要搬一次
按下去每個人都便宜
這一招對模型裡面負責思考的那些區塊完全有效
因為那些權重是全部人共用的
搬一次服務所有人
這件事有一個你每天看得到的商業版本
這家模型供應商都有一種批次的API
API就是程式跟模型下單的窗口
不急著要結果
價格就直接打對摺
他們敢賣半價
靠的就是把很多人的請求
湊成一大批一起算
搬一次權重服務更多人
可是他對注意力機制完全無效
原因就是上集講過的那本筆記
KV Cash
每一個人的對話都不一樣
筆記本都是他自己專屬的
Percy用了一個很好的說法
他說 在注意力這裡
每一條序列的筆記都是他自己獨一無二的雪花
你多服務一個人
你就多搬一整本筆記
這個成本貪不掉
所以注意力那個筆值永遠是一加再多的人也不會變
Percy在課堂上實際用紙筆算過一次
一個130億參數的模型
放在單張H100上面
一次只服務一個人
大概每秒可以吐124個字
你想把它加大到同時服務256個人
往時那些筆記本就要吃掉240GB的記憶體
這張卡根本放不下,所以你想省錢
你只有一條路,把筆記本本身變小
所以近幾年模型架構的改動
有一大半是被推理成本逼出來的
Percy說了一句很有意思的話
這堂課名義上在講推理
偷偷的其實在講模型架構
把那本筆記變薄
業界大概有四招
第一招上集講過讓好幾個注意力頭共用同一本筆記
那就是GQA LAMA 3
全系列都用了第二招更激進
是DeepSync第二代模型的做法
它們不是共用筆記
是把筆記整個壓縮過再存
這種時候在還原這一招叫MAA
Percy給了一個數字
原本每個字要記16000個數字
壓縮之後只剩512個
第三招是限制記憶的範圍
不是每一層都回頭看全部的歷史
大部分的層只看最近的一小段
Character AI的配方是
每六層裡面只留一層看得到全文
其他五層只看附近
第四招是讓不同的層共用同一份筆記
等於好幾層樓共用同一個倉庫
你注意到沒有
這四招沒有一招是在讓模型變聰明
全部都是在讓那本筆記變薄
這就是推理成本反過來改造模型架構最直接的證據
剛才四招有一個共同點
GQA也好 MLA也好都是設計圖上的決定
模型還沒開始訓練就得先想好
訓練完就改不動了
可是還有一整層是模型都訓練完了
準備要出場了
你在最後一刻再壓它一次
第一種壓法叫量化
模型裡面每一個權重都是一個數字
推理的時候通常用兩個位元組來存量化
就是問
能不能少寫幾位
你可以想成同一本筆記
你換一支更細的筆
重抄一遍
內容沒變
結束卻少了
壓成int bar
再壓成int 4
權重佔了空間剩下四分之一
前面那個瓶頸就鬆開了
這一招只給推理用
訓練的時候還是需要精度
麻煩的是硬壓會壓壞
問題處在少數幾個特別大的數字
這些叫離群值
有一篇叫做LLM Interbar的論文
做法很直接
把那幾個維度抽出來
用高精度算
剩下的全部壓掉
後來的AWQ更進一步
改看模型拋起來時激活值多大
這個決定哪一小撮全重不能壓
第二種壓法就沒那麼客氣了
既然有些層本來就沒什麼貢獻
那就直接把幾頁撕掉
NVIDIA的MINITRON
先用一小批資料量出來
哪幾層最不重要
然後整層整層砍掉
砍完模型會變笨
所以還有第三步
與原本那顆完整的大模型當老師
把砍掉的能力再交回來一次
有沒有發現
剛才這一整排招數
都有一個共同的心虛之處
不管是把筆記變薄
還是把數字寫小
本質上都是在丟掉一些資訊
模型是不是變笨了一點
你其實不知道
Percy說有一個辦法可以兩全其美
而且它是有數學保證的
叫Speculative Decoding
中文可以說成推測式解碼
它的直覺其實只有一句話
檢查筆生成快
生成是一個字一個字來的很慢
可是檢查一段已經寫好的文字
那是把整段一次讀完
是快的那一種
所以做法就變成
準備一個很小的模型當草稿手
讓他一口氣往前寫五個字
然後你把這五個字一次交給大模型
大模型用讀的一次驗完
前三個字他同意
第四個字不同意
那就從第四個字開始改寫
後面的作廢
你可以想成一隻兔子
在前面連續跳
留下五個腳印
烏龜在後面一次
把五個腳印全部檢查完
最精彩的是那個數學保證
接受草稿的規則被設計得非常巧妙 最後吐出來的文字
幾率分佈跟大模型自己慢慢寫是完全一樣的 不是差不多是完全一樣
而速度大概快一倍 還有一層省錢的地方 不在模型裡 在系統裡
Percy在最後講了一個我覺得非常有畫面的故事
那些筆記本要放在顯示卡的記憶體裡 而每一段對話會有多長
你事先根本不知道 所以最早的做法是幫每一段對話先劃一塊
很大的連續空間 結果就是記憶體被切得零零碎碎
中間卡著很多用不到的空洞
明明總量
還有就是塞不進新的對話
這正是作業系統課本第一章
在講的事情
所以VLM那篇論文的做法
就是直接把作業系統那一套搬過來
把筆記切成一塊
一塊固定大小的頁
愛放哪裡放哪裡
再用一張表記住順序
而且他連寫實複製都學了
兩段對話
如果開頭一樣
他們就共同一塊
直到其中一段開始分叉
才真的複製一份同一層
還有一個很小
但最有感的改動
廢物裡,只要有人先講完他就馬上補一個新的人進來,不用等整批一起結束
叫Continuous batching,中文可以說成連續批次
Percy講到這裡笑著說還記得你的作業系統課嗎?拿來用在推理上就對了
我很喜歡這個例子,因為這個領域看起來每天都在發明新東西
可是很多最有效的做法,是把幾十年前就解過的問題重新搬過來用一次
你把前面這一整段連起來看,會看到三種完全不同的態度
第一種是讓那本筆記變薄共用它
壓縮它只留最近的一段
第二種是換一個人先寫草稿
讓大模型只負責檢查
可是還有第三種
最徹底的乾脆不要那本筆記
Hershey在第十講的最後說
Transformer
當初被設計出來的時候
根本沒有人在想推理這件事
注意力機制
加上一個字一個字往下寫
天生就被記憶體卡住
所以真正的問題也許不是怎麼省
可是要不要換一個底
他講了兩條路
第一條叫狀態空間模型
他不把每一個字的筆記都留著,只是維護一份固定大小的記憶
你跟他聊十句還是一萬句,他身上帶的那份記憶永遠是同一個大小
推理成本就不會隨著對話變長一直往上爬
第二條路是擴散語言模型,他連一個字一個字往下寫都不做
先鋪一整片雜訊,再一輪一輪把它修清楚,整段文字幾乎是一起浮現的
我要很誠實的講後面這一半,狀態空間模型有明顯的弱點
你問他剛才那個名字是誰 他容易想不起來
所以現在能打的做法 還是要留幾層真正的注意力 回去看全文
這兩條路 要到今天都還沒有取代Transformer
可是他們為什麼存在?
答案就在這一整幕裡
就是推理的成本已經把人逼到要去掀桌子了
模型 訓好了也跑得動了
剩下最後一個問題他到底有多好
第十二講的講者一樣是Persilion
他一開場就把大家最想聽的那個答案否定掉了
他說不存在唯一正確的評測
這句話聽起來像在打太極
其實非常實用
他舉的例子是
同一個模型在同一個測驗上考了91分
這個91分對四種人的意義完全不同
對一個要採購的公司來說
他想知道的是這個模型能不能撐住我的客服
對一個做研究的人來說
他想知道的是這一年到底有沒有進步
對一個管政策的人來說
他想知道的是這東西會不會出事
對一個正在開發模型的工程師來說
他想知道的是
我上禮拜那個改動到底有沒有用
同一個數字,四個問題,答案完全不一樣
所以Percy說,你要先想清楚你在回答什麼問題
再去挑對應的評測
而且他提醒了一件很多人會忽略的事
很多排行榜上都少了一個軸成本,同樣91分
一個回答一次要幾百美元,一個一次只要幾分錢
放在同一張榜上,比本身就是誤導
Percy接著帶大家走了一段很有意思的樓梯
2020年出現一個叫MMLU的測驗
57個科目的選擇題
題目從網路上找來
GPT-3,那時候大概考45分,現在的前沿模型普遍在90分以上,分數上去了
題目就不夠用了,於是出現了加難版,把4個選項加到10個,再把那些本身有問題的題目挑掉
Percy說,那個理由很誠實,大家都90分,你不能全班都給A
再往上一階叫GPQA,是博士等級的題目,而且被設計成搜尋引擎,查不到
出題的人要確認一件事,一個非該領域的人給他30分鐘,加上一臺可以上網的電腦
他還是答不出來
真正的領域專家做這份題目大概拿65分
非專家帶著搜尋引擎只拿30分
GPT-4當時考39分
而Percy說
現在的O-Sign已經到75分了
所以在上面又蓋了一階
叫Humanities' Last Exam
翻成中文是人類的最後一次考試
Percy講到這裡的評語是
名字都取成這樣了
我不知道之後還能叫什麼
考試題會被追評
那換一種評法呢
有一個很受歡迎的做法叫Chatbot Arena
它不考試
他讓路人隨便丟一個問題
兩個模型各給一個回答
但不告訴你誰是誰
你只要選你比較喜歡哪一個
累計很多場
再用下棋那套積分制度算出排名
這個設計亮的是真實使用者的偏好
不是考試技巧
可是Percy說這個榜也出事了
有一篇論文叫The Leaderboard Illusion
翻成中文是排行榜的錯覺
它揭露某些廠商拿到的特權
可以私下多次提交自己的模型
來挑分數最好的那一次公開
另外一個更早被玩壞的例子
是用模型當裁判的評測
後來大家發現
只要回答寫得長一點
裁判就給比較高的分數
跟內容好不好無關
Percy把這些現象串成一句話
這就是Good Heart定律
一個指標一旦變成目標
它就會被玩壞
而評測的角色
比大家想象的重要得多
追蹤哪一個數字
全世界的實驗室
就會把模型往那個方向做評測
不是事後的計分板
而是方向盤
Percy在最後留了一個問題
我覺得那是整堂課最好的一句
他說你要分清楚兩件事
一個是有人在考你
一個是有人在問
考你的人自己知道答案
只是想看你會不會
問你的人是真的不知道
他需要你的幫忙
而我們現在幾乎所有的標準測驗
都屬於前面那一種
真正產生價值的卻是後面那一種
這個落差說明了
為什麼榜上的分數
跟你自己的體感常常對不上
Percy還補了兩件殺風警的事
第一件是汙染
現在的訓練資料是整個網絡
而考題也在網絡上
業界的做法是把
跟題目重疊的訓練文件刪掉
可是這支擋得住
一字不差的複製改寫過的
跟翻譯過的全部都穿得過去
第二件更有意思
有些數學測驗大家都考90幾分了
剩下答錯的那幾題仔細去看
大概有一半根本是標準答案標錯了
所以你以為模型還差最後那幾分
其實它差的不是能力
是那份考卷本身有錯
這兩件事加起來的意思是
分數不會自己說明自己
也知道它是怎麼量出來的
終極走到這裡
我想把三個判斷留給你
第一個判斷是
平行化不是演算法問題
是地理問題
把模型切成幾份
切在哪一刀
答案不是從數學推出來的
是你機房的線路長度決定的
通訊最密的那種切法
必須帶在同一臺機器裡面
這就是為什麼
張量平行的答案永遠是8
以後看到任何一家公司
公佈訓練配置
都可以反過來讀
他們配置在告訴你
他的機器之間有多快
第二個判斷是
比例不是常數
是財務決定
20比1從來不是自然定律
它是那個年代的最佳解
今天大家把資料量往上堆
不是因為發現了新的規律
是因為訓練負一次
推理要負一輩子
第三個判斷是
數字要先問怎麼量的
再問是多少
從上集那張規格表上的星號
到排行榜上
被多次提交挑出來的最好成績
再到那些標準答案標錯的考題
都在講同一件事
任何一個數字
都帶著它的良策條件
你不知道條件
就不知道那個數字在說什麼
上集我教你算賬
中集其實是在教你懷疑
A集我們把三個問題走完了
怎麼把模型切到幾千張卡上面
在花錢之前就決定要花多少
還有花完之後那個分數能不能信
這三件事共用同一種能力
就是在看到任何一個漂亮的數字之前
先問它是在什麼條件下亮出來的
最後問你一個問題
如果現在有人給你十萬張顯示卡用一個月
你會拿去訓練一個更大的模型
還是訓練一個小很多
但是為了超薄的模型
然後讓它服務更多人
留言告訴我
下集我們會走進課程的後半段
資料是從哪裡來的
怎麼洗乾淨
還有訓練完之後的對齊
跟後訓練那一段
喜歡的話
訂閱AI Notebook
開啟通知
追蹤
後續下次見